Americans see the Middle East on the
brink with an Israeli ground invasion of
Gaza set to occur any day now Secretary
of State Tony blinkin has been over
there for days and someone even leaked
his itinerary down to the excruciating
detail to the New York Times today did
you read that our secretary of state
going there okay that's one thing but
why on Earth is Joe Biden flying to
Israel what's the purpose does Israel
really need another distraction or a
daughtering Biden to look over the
shoulder of
Netanyahu and then the cancellation of
the summit with the Middle East leaders
that I mentioned earlier that's just
embarrassing and it's an obvious sign
that they neither fear the us nor want
our help in diffusing the situation
either way another black eye for an
already battered foreign policy
reputation joining us now Ben D menic
Fox News contributor and editor- at
large as The Spectator and Ned Ryan
founder and CEO of American majority Ben
this seems like more performance art
than art F diplomacy yeah just a little
bit Laura I mean I don't think anybody
actually wants Joe Biden in the room for
any of this it's not like he's going to
add anything to the discussion really
you're just going to have to sit there
and put up with him daughtering as he
does in so many of these foreign policy
situations you know pretending like he's
still the head of the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee and Meandering and
recollecting the past you know get
telling old fish stories and like look
the the Biden Administration has all
sorts of things to answer for as when it
comes to uh implementing policy that led
us up to this crisis that led us up to
this war of coddling Iran for so long
the the JV team from the Obama era
they're all back in charge they've led
us to this point and the fact that he's
going over there is it's totally a
distraction it's not going to help at
all and frankly the israelies are
perfectly capable of responding maybe we
should send Susan Rice over there and
Cheryl Mills like get the whole crowd
back get the whole game back um let's
let's talk about this a little bit
though Ned because it's it's it's more
than just symbolism it's also a reality
on the ground there are fires reported
outside the US Embassy in Lebanon
tonight there are other protests that
are growing across the globe so Biden
could actually be adding kerosene to the
fire instead of diffusing the
situation no I I I don't disagree with
that at all Laura I mean it is his
incredible weakness and has Ben pointed
out failed policies that that are
literally melting the world if you think
about his his foreign policy RIT large
whether it's in Europe or it's in the
Middle East I mean the the world is
collapsing because of his weakness
because of his pursuit of failed
policies which are a continuation of
Obama's failed policies and here we
stand finding ourselves again Iran has
has been empowered by Biden not only
with with releasing cash but also
because he's lifted sanctions it's given
him another 80 to 90 billion in oil
Revenue since he began his
administration which to highlight how
much that is in the last year of trump
it was only 7.9 billion that's a lot of
money to fund Hamas and Hezbollah and
then on top of that Laura the the
amazing part to me is him showing up in
Israel which he's been undercutting for
the last two and a half years really
demonstrating to its enemies he doesn't
care about Israel or its leadership and
then we find out today insult to injury
that Biden's nominee for the ambassador
to Israel as Jack Lou Who oversaw the
infamous transfer pallets of cash to
Iran Obama the complete disdain that
Biden has shown Israel has empowered his
enemies their enemies and now he's
empowered Iran even more this is all for
his all of his doing and he's only going
to make the situation worse until they
until they decide that there will not be
a continuation of the failed Iranian
policy the Middle East will continue to
be destabilized and I also make the
further point that a weak America at
home is not a strong America abroad when
our economy is in the situation is that
doesn't help either no it doesn't help
at all and Laura I think the thing that
we should be most concerned about is if
Joe Biden goes over there and decides to
really
medal in what Israel wants to do we've
seen this kind of creeping uh movement
in a direction that basically says well
you know the israelies we don't want to
overreact too much to the worst attack
on the Jewish people since the end of
the Holocaust you know we we don't we
don't want things to go too far no they
should be left to solve their own
business they're perfectly capable of
doing it themselves and Joe Biden has no
business uh lecturing them about
strategy or what he believes they ought
to do in this situation they couldn't
withdraw from Afghanistan Ned I mean
he's going over there tell the Israelis
how to run their military response to to
Gaza and meanwhile you got the
progressive caucus with t saying back
off basically don't you dare I mean he's
getting pushed uh pushed back from his
own uh Left Flank the the most important
thing that Biden can do literally in
this situation is shut up and let Israel
deal with Hamas in a definitive way that
it's decimated and never Rises up again
as a a threat to Israel the most
important thing is we stay out of
Israel's way in this moment and and and
the the other thing that we can do as we
stay out of Israel's way is make sure
that Iran China Russia whoever else
keeps their distance as well let Israel
deal with the threat and stay out of the
way that's the most important thing the
Biden Administration can do but I agree
with Ben there's a reason that blink's
been over there there's a reason reason
that Biden is going and I suspect
they're trying to talk Israel out of
doing what it needs to do to remove
Hamas as a threat which is shameful and
Lincoln's getting his mail for over
there he's been so long he's been there
for what 10 days back and forth panel
great to see you both hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else